we do this thing called unhelpful advice
okay
I'm helpful bias with Bobby kalila and
Jo koy hey that was pretty good
I like that one more time one more time
unhelpful virus little Bobby
kalila and the man with money Jojo I
like I don't see her name just a first
name okay this is Lisa
I need help la is filled with basic
vanilla boring guys and I can't seem to
find anyone who has a better person uh
who has a better personality than my big
toe
I've been single for a while now and it
kind of sucks not because I'm single but
the thought of going through bags of
dicks before actually finding someone
remotely chill and interesting do I have
to admit that la is a [ __ ] dick
desert I know you can help me please
help a girl out and this is a very cute
because la is a dick desert we have a
photo it's very yeah III can vouch she's
cute now let me see the photo that's
like I can't okay it doesn't matter what
she looks like this is a girl who's
trying to find you know more than just a
bad day yeah yeah and then assume a
daughter I cannot answer the question
yes sweetie it's the real let's be real
okay
I feel like this that's what she looks
like pixelated let me see yeah cute
super cute yeah cute break you all right
well that's all I needed guidance up
although she does look miss that's just
an emo kind of girl girl killer so check
this out check it out how old is she
young she's probably in her 20s it looks
like which means she's probably 36 yeah
cuz she's 37 and she speaks like a 36
year old yeah 20 a 22 year old still
hope Asian girl would not be talking
yeah I'm so happy to be here
so many dicks it's like a dick
and I love desert if she was if she was
living in Lubbock Texas yeah you know it
would be the same complaint
oh yeah that's because there's less
there's less options yeah so one of my
point is is that yes there's a lot of
[ __ ] shitty dudes in LA that you're
gonna have to [ __ ] that's everyone we
have to you know mean we have to go
through the bags of dicks and roses to
find the one that fits your situation
you know how explain Hollywood can I
jump in real quick okay yeah everyone is
from like a a small town I'm from Tacoma
Washington yeah it's just there's nobody
out there but when you went to school
there was always that one dick probably
good-looking little talented when he
graduated where'd he go Hollywood so
every small town that had that dick that
was kind of cute and yeah I've had
Talent that dude is here yeah so in your
town it was just one dick you come to
Hollywood all the dicks are here and now
they're competing against now they're
meeting against what yeah that's that's
that's my that's a and that same thing
for the women by the way you know I mean
but also the nerds came out here - yeah
the nerds came out here because those
are the ones that edit right and they're
good with computer or the animate and
stuff like that that's a lot of creative
people are on out here a lot of
creatively right so you're gonna have to
go through all the dicks and then you go
through that's see I think for a lot of
people these days it's like they go
through the burnout of tinder like
everything is just easy and accessible
and convenient and you can do it out of
the you know so you will if you just
want casual dick yeah that is the way to
go but if you're anything yeah if you're
looking for something meaningful I don't
think that that online apps is the way
to go I think it is I know that's how we
met but that's how we that's and also
whatever first started I've said this
before okay you think about your daily
life all right I'm going to tell you
explain to my life I wake up around 2:30
p.m. I drink a Red Bull yeah and then
I'll go kitchen gives me good music
behind this yeah algorithm to eat yeah
now go I'll go to a coffee shop try to
write a joke and I'll go to the comedy
store doing my set come home play video
games till 3:00 4:00 in the morning and
then gonna sleep right up tired
I know I was surprised but yeah that's
it everyday right and so it along that
path of behavior
you're only gonna run into people the
same people yeah
the same people obviously right this and
that yeah you're what tinder does it
expands your horizons I would have never
met kalila with that tinder right but
what I don't see this though when you at
her met it was at the beginning stages
of that creepy now it's it's really I
was very different as how it was being
used and I I'm telling you right now
there were some decent people on there
I'm not saying there aren't decent
people on tinder now but it's different
the idea is if I match with someone it's
basically for casual sex it's not really
to get to know them yeah and I use
ginger for casual sex - yeah but I've
met somebody that didn't want to just
have sex casual sex and then I met her I
met her and I'm like oh this is a
connection that's you know mean yeah so
that my first intention wasn't to find a
[ __ ] soul mate my first intention was
I want to get some [ __ ] fast what do we
tell this girl then is it just join all
the bumbles isn't that go on she's 22
right
she 22 we don't have any she's young
look at the face she's in the [ __ ]
20s right I didn't meet her until I was
42 put yourself out there
I know I I don't really believe her her
texts by the way I don't think she's
Hollywood is not full of a bunch of
dicks oh you're right there are three
she's like I don't know she's had a
couple bad dates and that's it for her
yeah there's a lot of nice people there
we go that's what I'm saying and and
also you know I do have friends whose
standards are so high yeah and you just
kind of like why do you care does he
have to be just why does he have to have
a helicopter
yeah I do think you should you know what
you can want your cake and then eat it
so you can have the whole thing but also
be reasonable you know within limits
it's like no he doesn't have to have a
helicopter and if he has a potbelly
that's okay he's missing gave her no
answer there's that we did know what
Bobby said was right go outside your
norm you want to meet some people that
change your here's the thing it doesn't
matter I get dicks if you go into the
same place it's not better anywhere else
is my point
no it isn't for her to go I'm gonna go
to Alaska well could go to a lot Alaska
you gonna find like that guy that smells
like fish yeah like 24/7 yeah you gonna
find a guy out there with a freezing
cold pink dick yeah that guy is right
here yeah yeah give it up for George Kim
oh yeah the white dudes in Alaska look
like him right yeah yeah that kind of
big sweater yeah yeah and the cross
little legs like Barbra ha you don't
paid [ __ ] bro starting a fight got a
look at how [ __ ] fancy thinks yeah
yeah yeah people to keep them stock
Clemson yeah oh I like that that is what
you do you verbally abuse people look at
the guy in the closet yes I said a
[ __ ] word I love him
oh really play it back to uh 9:30 to
play back-to-back 32 let me see
something
he'll remember thin lips when he said
thin lips to him it does he look like
Delroy Lindo to you you look like your
dad where'd you get your [ __ ] nose
remember that yeah you love him
it looks like big bird right over there
that knows look at that no he's gonna
beat what is okay you got parents yeah
why you gonna do why they lead you in
attack me what do you do what are you
gonna fight me
get the goddamn closet why is the door
open yeah bastard you're a painter so
guys um that was fun when it would have
put some dates what do you want to plug
I don't need to hold out yeah but I II
listen I even if they're sold out he'll
have a show and we've using your show in
your town yeah you mean check it out and
um I'm not here to plug Sheila's man I'm
friends with you we are friends Oh are
we gonna talk again or yeah yeah I got a
do your podcast I want to do it tomorrow
exactly I can do some more time what
tonic
11:00 in the morning what'd he do surly
because that's when life starts life
starts in the morning life and debt note
you [ __ ] Korean vampire anyway um
check out a special on Netflix mm-hmm
nice yeah yeah that's nice high note say
something inspirational and positive
yeah let's close this yeah okay I'm
gonna think of the word I already know
that the words um in life yeah you run
into certain guys that's kind of a
mirror of what you want to be or you
want to surround yourself with and those
mirror images you run into time and time
again in your voyage and Joe is like
that for me he's somebody that I look up
to somebody that I respect and somebody
that um I think is extremely talented
and I know for the fact I know for the
rest of my life that I will always see
him you know he'll always be in my life
that's when we see each other like when
I was was drawn driving in it just
started you know the the the chemistry
the rapport I really love them you know
I
his family and he's a good dude okay
good yeah very good
that was really her thing yeah you're
thinking something yeah I am a liar a
known liar I'm a known liar
we know but I was nine that was that was
the truth I like that merciless before
you start write others okay turn it off
cool guys we'll be back in a bit yeah
[Music]